you cannot arest me I am above the
law I am above the law
nigga you cannot do nothing to me
okay I am the
law you're going to have to kill me a
home destroyed lengthy crisis
negotiations and an officer involved
shooting all that added up to a nearly
30h hour long standoff
before a North Carolina man with
multiple personalities and end of times
beliefs finally
surrendered I got cffs I got
cffs
my it All Began on March 11th 2023 in
Charlotte North Carolina just before
7:00 that morning dispatch received a
911 call reporting a man making threats
to kill his neighbors and police
officers Charlotte 911 do you need
police fire or medic I need
police and what's going on that you'll
need the police well I neighbor my
neighbor is threatening me threaten to
kill me threat to kill police I have it
on video we're
scared okay and when you say he's he's
threatening you he doing in person on
the phone what he on the phone with a
megaphone he's out in front of his yard
minutes later another 911 call came in
with a similar report Charlotte 911 do
you need police fire or
medic um I need police I need to file
communicating threats report I'm working
with
cmpd um crisis response team and um our
neighbor is threatening us currently and
the officer with uh crisis response told
us to call 911 to file a police report
officers with the Charlotte mecklinburg
Police Department arrived to a home on
the city's Southwest W side that's where
they learned the suspect and Tai had
barricaded himself inside police were
familiar with Tai though in fact they'd
been to his home 45 times before
starting in September 2017 body camera
video shows officers approached the
front door in an effort to take Tai into
custody there was an outstanding order
for his arrest based on past
incidents
he's at the door yelling with a
megaphone Ty can be heard in the video
yelling into a megaphone from inside the
house
you are not a police I am the president
of the
USA talking Donald John
Trump you come on
outside oh Mom's at the
door heads
up I thought she was why didn't she just
open the door
I saw somebody's hand was at the door
doing
this
um he always uses that window though I
think his room is on this side but he
always uses that window soon Tai's
mother comes to the door she explains
he's armed with at least one gun and
bullets good morning how
do
he on has a warrant
for his
arrest I don't know because I'm telling
we have to take him he has a war arrest
yet but I go to I go to the downtown
to the don't him go to the to jail today
yeah because don't take the go the
anything does he have any knives any
knives guns they have gun si si people
he has pills sit the gun have the
si uh revolver yeah he has that
yeah nobody take him
I'm
the more I can't
see I call the police up
okay him chcken but him M him very
chicken
okay where's the re the
gun
and here the S his room my house who
else is inside the house beside
you because Myro my husband di I come my
husband so who's here who is here you me
and here that's
it why don't we
huh yeah back and we'll try to talk him
out of the house without that him him
don't go out he doesn't go out but I
want the bullet when him go out the take
him because the one
day no him him don't go here
go we're going to try to get out of his
range in case he shoots he can't see us
to shoot so let's step over here because
of a language barrier officers speak
with Tai's sister over the phone
confirming his mother said there was a
weapon inside we're just trying to
clarify with the language barrier for
your mom but um we were trying to let
her know that an has a order for his
arrest to go to jail so we're trying to
peacefully get him out of the house come
outside but she's she's advising that he
has what we can best tell is a revolver
a gun I just want to confirm that he
does have that with your mom if you if
you can ask her if he does have a gun
yes yes of course all right go
ahead it's
time Char meber Police Department we're
outside we're not going anywhere we need
you to step outside with your hands
up
yesol Mr Ty okay this charlot Police
Department we need you to come outside
with your hands up
want does he have bullets in the
revolver is it loaded
yes two warrants for Tai's arrest were
then made as was an involuntary
commitment order meaning once Tai was
taken into custody he would receive
mental health treatment even if it was
against his will as Tai remained
barricaded inside officers broke down
the front door body camera video was
turned on just seconds before the door
was broken down which is why the first
few seconds are without
audio
239 or I will call you I just need you
to answer your
phone this is very important nobody is
here to hurt you we are only here to
help your mother's worried about
you we are here to make sure that you
get the you
need Hands
Up
Up answer your phone step out slow with
your hands
out nothing in your
hands Ty can be heard on the video
threatening to hurt himself and shoot
officers we do not want to hurt you to
the right we
[Applause]
he's put that stuff at the top of the
steps to barricade it I think he's to
the right
[Music]
negative all right go ahead
troll at the same time officers outside
began speaking with Tai via a
megaphone and we want to make sure
you're okay
we need you to come down to the front
door with nothing in your this is the
Charlotte mcber Police
Department we know you're inside we need
you to come outside with your hands up
through the front door Nothing in Your
Hands we would like this to end
peacefully we are not going anywhere Ty
responds using his megaphone discussing
religion and the
government you cannot arrest me I am a
the
law I have Above the Law
nig you cannot do nothing to me
okay I am above the
law you going to have to kill me I
Believe In Lord Jesus Christ okay and
you got to have to kill me and all the
Heavenly angels and Jesus Christ if you
want to arrest me okay I got the heav
angels and Satan and God and and Allah
and Mary Magdalene nig
the you can't touch me it's over about
three hours into the standoff First
Responders get tie on the phone and
begin negotiations you all want to
nobody wants to kill you I promise you
that I do not want to harm you and no
officer out here wants to hurt you that
I can promise
[Music]
you
okay but we're not leaving either all
right nobody wants to harm you and we
don't want you to harm yourself all
right isud broke my this is not War
break break my heart break my head you
break my neck you break my hand you
break my everything I have my dogs oh
see that's where you're wrong we don't
want to break anything of yours okay we
want you to get help you just
my I I spent an hour telling you that
was going to
happen all you had to do was give me a
call and you chose not to
okay I told I haven't lied to you one
bit
everything I've told you and said over
that loudspeaker has been the truth I
haven't
lied I told you we would damage your
mother's home if you didn't
right no we do not want you to hurt
yourself nope you don't want me to
myself I've told you the truth the whole
time we can't live here no
more the door can easily be fixed listen
I have faith that you can control that
voice okay okay then let me do it I have
faith that you can all right I'm just
shoot myself and get this voice no don't
let that Voice
win okay don't let the
voice
dude under my
control you are stronger than that okay
you can control this you can you can do
it listen you can do
it you can do it and I we can help you
you can you control your own mind don't
let those voices
win I told you I have to over control my
own mind calm down
slowly please I don't want to die I
don't want you to you I don't want you
to K me and be all stressed out we all
going to go home and enjoy our night and
the way why was so
hard we all going to go home at night
and door and act like all this never
happened so why are we work so hard
right now trying to killing each other
over some jealousy brother I don't want
to hurt you that I I don't want to hurt
you and I don't want you to hurt
yourself dude I am too anti dude I for
God all right you see me being a
preacher I'm out here saving Souls man
doing God work man I'm
not the police man I'm trying to make
you guys look good okay okay but now you
here trying to kill me that's not true
okay don't put those words in my mouth
and don't put that on me that is not
true we are here to help you that I can
promise these phone negotiations last
for multiple hours where Tai discusses
harming himself and later the goal of
becoming president this conversation's
gone a long way and you I can just tell
by your voice that you're doing a lot
better than when I first started talking
to
you wait
die all right brother help me man I need
I need help okay I need some buying on
you on your end all
right no I'm Ved than you right now okay
listen I know that we can do this
together and I know
and I know we can do this without
anybody getting
hurt no you're not you are not a loser
that's a wrong that's a that's a wrong
mental dude
like that's a
wrong don't you put that on my
conscience don't you
dare
pissed off for what pissed off for what
no why no why would you be pissed off I
I didn't hear
that I
wish oh so you want to meet them
yeah well I I've never met them and I
couldn't I I could shouldn't arrange
that meeting either I'm not going
to
I King I don't want you to kill yourself
nobody out
here no
no King we need you
here we need you
here your dogs need you here your mom
needs you
here and and and and I'll be honest like
like officer you were talking to before
officer Grant don't put that on our
conscience you
know
father
evil
I
stuff
okay okay but
King I live in this I live in this
neighborhood man I don't want to drive
by I don't want to drive by your house
house every day and think about the
decision that you made and that you're
not here with us anymore I want to think
about you being out here getting the
help you
deserve being here for your dogs that's
what I want to say I want
be I thought you didn't want to be the
president
here I
am all right so if you want to be the
president the first step is coming out
of that
house you can't you can't be the
president from in
there yes I can I can well a president
that I need doesn't rule from his
house that is true the
whitec I mean that's where you may lay
your head but you're going to need to do
your business out here
and and doing your business out here is
is coming out here listening to these
officers and I'm right here I'm right
here
[Music]
K
to
King why can't you just come out here
and talk to
[Music]
me
I don't want that I mean we have we have
an ambulance out here that can check you
out for
that
yeah I would feel better if you came up
here and we checked you out before that
even
happened hell King I'll ride to the
hospital with you if you
won't how do afraid of losing everything
I have in this house well well then well
then King King listen to what you just
said you're afraid of losing everything
in your house you're not going to lose
anything in your
house to be honest with you we don't
have a we don't have a necessity of
coming in your house if you come outside
we don't need to go in your
house you want me to be Hospital right
game no it's not the end game it's a
temporary situation
King I'm
good hpal stra check okay so King let me
ask you you shoot yourself that's
permanent right y That's
permanent y but go to hospital temporary
exactly
exactly so you're you're smart enough to
see that you're smart enough to see that
that's temporary and then you'll be
right back home with whatever you have
there in the house I don't need to come
in your
house no they're not they don't do that
anymore team they don't have the
resources for
thatal Hospital
history who claim to be the Antichrist
God which I'm done playing game I don't
want to be anti
well well then well then surrender that
role King surrender that role at one
point Tai admitted he had a gun and
walked to the front door of the home
with it in hand that's when the full
SWAT team was assembled as were crisis
negotiators
that's ready
yeah sh get out go
go
at this point officials sent multiple
drones inside the home and began
removing the doors and windows to the
house to get better access at one point
Ty rushes from a room and attacks a
drone damaging it you can see him walk
from that room and smack the Drone with
a bat around the same time First
Responders cut the
power
[Applause]
we just had to hit all I hit the main
one and then I just hit all them just to
sure at about 9 p.m. Tai again
approached officers with a weapon one
officer opened fire but no one was
injured at first though Tai said he had
been shot that's when he called 911
saying his past body was dead and that
he was now Lucifer police say he showed
multiple personalities throughout the
standoff charlot 911 do you need police
fire or medic I saw the police shot uh a
person because he was holding a gun
poting at police and the police shot him
he's dead I need to make a police report
okay well where you at so we can make
that report I'm in heaven oh okay I'm a
GH yes my name is
Lucifer I'm not real all right I'm in
heaven okay and I saw and I saw I'm mess
of God all right God the Holy Bible I
swear by the name of Jesus Christ I saw
the police kill this idiot who holding
his gun cock back pointing at them
knowing well that's a sniper across the
street throughout this all First
Responders continued to make entry into
the home even going through back
windows
during the night officials broke down
the doors to the garage eventually
pulling off most of that area of the
home in the same time frame Tai
continued to yell out to First
Responders using a megaphone I have this
all
America I an AR an a I have no master no
government
I govern my
own I am an an AR I don't need
government this is why I don't come out
I am not a US of a
citizenship I am an
an and First Responders called
[Music]
back
on
the all right we're going to get back to
this body cam in a second but I want to
take a minute to talk about something
else that happens all the time workplace
injuries if you get hurt at your job
whether it's a slip and fall a
mechanical failure negligence of your
co-workers something hits you you're
going to need a trusted law firm in your
corner enter Pon Le hockey geordano a
firm that is a heavyweight in the
industry that wins all different kinds
of injury cases yes workplace but also
accidents Social Security Disability
injuries they have a track record of
recovering over $1 billion for their
clients and they have won over a 100,000
cases they have 250 years of combined
experience how amazing is that so you
can check out ponle hocky geordano at
ponle hockey.com
LC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body cam more than
24 hours after the standoff began Tai
finally surrendered and was taken into
custody these moments were caught from
multiple angles keep walking towards the
sound of our
voice you Swit up with wall can
we right
yes I got cuffs I got cuffs that 40 mm
needs to be ready de is you
ready keep walking towards the sound of
our
voice up with
W I got cops I got cops I
Surrender we got it4 we got
it please don't shoot
me don't need help no we don't need the
help you see me my back right all right
listen up everybody bre all my jewelry
please don't break all my jewelry I
we're going to hold the house don't
break all my jewelry please give me stop
I'm sorry IE
for I give up okay all right let's get a
good fres set the bag off
I'm standing on
that
yeah we got hang on hang on mat you hey
Matt I'm right here dude I'm right here
thank you for coming out I'll
call phone in left hand phone in left
hand dog in right wants a surrender
walking
[Music]
out all right coming pass the garage B
left hand dog still in the
right
all right they're verbal with him you
just keeps looking back at the house
phone in left hand little doggy in the
right he's trying to walk through all
this stuff in the front
[Music]
yard left coat pocket looks
heavy
72 he's in custody
72 no no come on you're good on come on
sir I got you come on to me just be
careful you're good come on come
on y
hey I can't walk yeah come on you keep
walking you're good bring the dog with
you come on don't kill my dog oh we're
not Brother come
on come on keep walking yep you're good
bro come come on keep
walking yeah your dog's good come on I
havea okay okay got
you keep coming to us don't shoot me
we're not going to shoot you you keep
coming to us you're doing good my just
you're fine keep walking towards us keep
your hands ready you're good you're good
we see your dog see your
pH you're good auntie keep walking
towards us brother you're doing
good keep walking
do keep walking toward the sound of my
[Music]
voice during his arrest a gun fell from
Tai's pocket but what may be more
shocking is the absolute disaster left
behind in the home body camera video
captures the house that appears largely
destroyed after the 30-hour
standoff I'm right here okay I turn my
back to you that me you yeah I'm right
here let him check you out I know
officer video then captures the moments
after Tai is taken into custody you're
good you're good I dropped my glasses
they broke broke I know got get
my my got got wear let me wear I'm blind
without mycri you're good ition you're
good I'm blind
dude I can't see without my
prescription me my prescription dude
give me my prescription
please on the
phone all right I'm let me wear that let
me wear that clear this we got I told
you it's all Bo trash hey
probably I can't goad keep it safe while
you at it I can't have you going to the
hospital without checking doing get me
my I got you where where are they at do
you know it's when I dropped it my
prescription you dropped them okay I'll
go get it get my prescription I'll go
get it stay cool with them and I'm going
I'm cool bro I need bodyguards okay not
my guns
everywhere give me the out here hurry up
please
can't trust n y'all all
right this dude trying to break my arm
all
right dude there's nothing in there
beside my
please dude don't stay
my one pie keep your glass right here
good he's only got one W
you Happ to be a math genius all right
you want me to put your glass back my
prescription please my
prescription right what is that a
r good yeah yeah turn around man let's
get your bag off all right yeah get my
bag
off I know y'all got shoot that's why I
turn my back I'm not
stop stop I'm right
here yeah
got get my classes you want these yes
you want put them on yes and my
prescription all I need is prescription
we're going to go look for your
prescriptions once he's taken from the
scene and appears to be in the hospital
Tai asks about the condition of his home
and who's going to pay for it do me a
favor you sit on this for
me we'll make sure that everything is
okay make sure nobody trying to fight me
well we're not trying to do that I
promise no the mentally Pati oh
[Music]
okay so somebody over there watching my
house right I believe so and who's going
to who going to clean it up fix it all I
have no information Amer police or the
city right I have no information you
going leave it like that I have no
information on that at this point who
take responsibilities for fixing the
house I have no information on that are
usually stuff like that who pay for the
fixing of the
house make sure nothing onbody break
everything in the house
SW so he just let sit like that un
livable fix it
no that's crazy I lost my whole
house just believeing the
FBI a
Cho Tai was charged with multiple counts
of communicating threats and violating a
protective order but those charges were
dropped he's still awaiting trial though
for charges of assaulting a law
enforcement officer with a firearm
reporting for La crime I'm Sierra
Gillespie